I'm Jade I'm an advanced research
assistant in seller operations at the
welcome Sanger Institute
cellular operations is a massive
Pipeline and it starts from the
generation of the cancer organoids to
the screening of the cancer organoids to
the use of them in clinical research
the aim of my past pipeline is to ensure
that the cancer organoids are expressing
the markers that we want to see so that
they can be used in clinical research
a typical day for me involves checking
the organized under the microscope to
make sure they're growing and they're
healthy I take a picture of them and
then add it to our electronic lab book
get the reagents I need and prepare the
hood
the two main systems we use in our
pipeline are the crispr castline gene
editing tool used to insert or remove
jeans and the grna screen where we use a
virus to insert a specific marker into
the gene of a cancer organoid to see if
it's been expressed
yeah I'm definitely very excited working
vulvanoids as models for cancer
development they're relatively new in
the field and there's still loads to
find out about them and how they work
and how they interact with each other
you just don't know where they're going
to take future developments in cancer
treatments
although I work alone on my project I
work in a massive team so we get to
socialize we talk to each other and help
each other out and yeah we listen to a
bit of music sometimes
[Music]
to be a scientist you need to be
tenacious because not every experiment
is going to go to plan you're going to
experience a lot of failures things can
be very unpredictable you do have to
think on your feet and be able to adapt
I always knew that I wanted to be in
science so I started off doing gccs like
any other school student I did
additional science then I went on to my
a levels when a bit overboard I did
psychology chemistry physics and biology
and yes my head exploded so I dropped
out after the first year
um and went on to a b-tech in applied
science and then with that natural
diploma I got into the University of
Worcester and I studied animal biology
after University I worked at the Francis
Cricket Institute where I stayed for six
years in various different roles then
after the Francis Crick I moved to
lasagna I do enjoy being a scientist
every time I say oh I'm a scientist
people are like what they just don't
know how to react and then yeah having
to explain afterwards what I actually do
is even more confusing in the future I'd
like to stay in science that's where I'm
meant to be scientific Field's always
changing there's always things to learn
when I was in school I could have never
imagined myself working with cancer
organoids because they weren't even a
thing when I was in school
but I'm glad that life has ended up this
way and it's taken me here there's still
much to learn from counter organoids I
think it's just a start it's just the
beginning
[Music]